Finally, the time has come. We're going to graph y equals 3 x minus 5. I'm going
to set up our x and y axis according to these ranges of values that you just
picked. So, I've drawn our basic x and y cooridinates. That we are eventually,
pretty soon, I promise, going to draw these points on. But remember, we need to
label the crosshatches on either axis, so that we show what the scale of each
axis is. So, I'm going to put a box here, a box here, box here, and a box here.
These are tiny boxes. Yours will show up bigger on the screen, I promise. And
I'd like you to tell me for these two boxes what the x-coordinate of each one
is, and for these two boxes what the y-coordinate is for each. This is going to
show, basically, how much moving from here to here on the y-axis counts as we're
counting, and how much moving from here to here on the x-axis counts.